foreign  all right come over here to us right now  okay  all right if I have to come in there and  get you it's going to be not a good day  okay  so do you want to do this the hardware  the easy way  you walk up there right now or I'm gonna  come in there and we'll walk up there  together how about that  all right well are you done  are you done  I guess we're on the water go on the  land and we'll talk to you how about  that  crazy bro it is crazy you're in the  water get out of the water no  you got one more opportunity okay  and then I'm gonna come in there and get  you we'll walk to the shore together how  about that  yeah  all right  you guys gonna be a bad day  foreign  [Music]